quarterback of your Chicago Bears on
behalf of gone rogue which I believe
he'll explain shortly he's none other
than Mitch true Biscay how are you sir
of course so I guess this is the first
thing we gotta get to Mitch or Mitchell
let's get let's get right to it here
what is it what do you said Mitch for
Biscay solo steak wasn't it no don't be
like that
cuz I think you know I know is it no
it's really cool it's cool
are you sure I really I was just telling
somebody earlier how I just had I got so
many nicknames the Mitch Mitchell though
I'm a kind of behind me I'm like I deal
with the nicknames now it's either money
Mitch true okay mr. Biskit all these
crazy ones mr. Biskit mr. Biskit we're
just we're just Biscay like it doesn't
matter no I well well I mean there are
short versions of my name that people
would never say to my face you know so
they might say it behind my back
you know so I guess in that respect I'm
a little touchy on what people call me
doesn't matter cause we heard when you
came out I guess from between years 1 &
2 it's Mitchell like that's what we
heard media yeah but didn't come from
you well that's always been my name and
then when I got drafted they just wanted
to shorten it which I was cool with but
people thought I had a problem with it
which I didn't so ok it was like so I
was like if it's Mitchell if it's Mitch
I'm gonna answer to either one I as long
as my last name so Biscay I'm good with
it okay well this is a radio simulcast
so if you don't mind every now and then
when I reset the conversation who I'm
talking to I'm gonna use a different
version that fine okay okay I'm here
with Biscay the Bears quarterback here
on the rich on Jojo okay so what is life
like for you right now here in early May
getting set for your 3rd season in the
NFL walk me through what life is like
for you it's awesome it's really good to
be back in Chicago with all with all the
guys back in
just working through OTA is going
through year three for me but really
you're too in this offense just getting
all the guys back you've added new
pieces that's all season we're very
excited to tick back up where we left
off and we just got a chip on her
shoulder it was working really hard and
there's new goals and expectations
heading into this year so there's a lot
of excitement around the team and we're
going to build off that chemistry and
that great team bond we got going and
see what we can do this year so the
excitements very high end though which
couldn't be more answer this offseason
hits this even so you know the
conversation is certainly in the NFL
last few years young coach come being
brought in specifically to bring along a
highly drafted quarterback going from
year one a year to the Los Angeles Rams
did it for instance everybody trying to
get the same version of that it
certainly looks like Matt Negi was the
perfect guy at the perfect time for you
what would you say to that I would say
absolutely we've been very lucky to have
Coach Nagy he's one of the best I've
been around if not the best just
absolutely genius when it comes to
offense and Cohen plays but he's an even
better person just how he is on a
personal level his passion for the game
how he cares about his players his
competitiveness how he motivates guys
and unites the team and brings everyone
together he's he I couldn't ask for a
better guy to play for and he came in he
embraced me from day one and he's really
excited about what I could do in his
offense and he just continued to
pleasing me and that's a player that's
all you can ask for so I'm I'm gonna
continue to give everything I got for
from my teammates and coach and we're
gonna roll it's been awesome having him
give me an example of what he unlocked
for you again going from year one a year
to as he came in for you at that very
crucial part of your career what what
did he do specifically that unlocked you
the way what you saw you play last year
yeah definitely I think just bringing
his offense and just really opening it
up and then trusting me with the keys
and let me play my game just running
around swinging the ball and
trusting his his scheme and his timing
was an offense and obviously it was a
learning process but him just believing
in me and allowing me to play my game
and use my skill set and can open up and
and even make mistakes and learn from
them and just continue to grow and
continue to get better better within
those offenses it's allowed us to it
helped me grow a lot as a player and and
it helped us often get a lot better as
well so it's not just me though we got a
great coaching staff and I have a baby
teammate sue who do most of the work and
really make this thing go so I'm here
with Bears quarterback mr. Biskit uh
here on the Rich Eisen show right now so
let's talk about your was that did they
work that in properly Mitchell is that a
good version of it okay yeah thank you I
appreciate that so much being made about
kids who were just got drafted and the
fact that they didn't have much
experience at the controls let's just
say let me just choose a certain confer
Toby ACC and Daniel Jones in particular
and so much the people think that
perhaps he's not ready for the bright
lights what would you say for somebody
who didn't have much experience coming
out of North Carolina as you did right
so I mean every everybody situation is
different
Daniel played more games than I did and
I think you had Dwayne who only started
one year and Kaila only started one year
as well so all these young quarterbacks
can taken early you're gonna have a lot
of people on the outside the media or
fans who without you coming in but you
got picked for a reason and you gotta
believe that that team believes in you
and you just got to continue to do what
you've done to get to that point and
that's just work hard stay true to
yourselves they choose the game and and
just grind it out but there's gonna be
adversity along the way and as long as
you have a positive mindset about it and
attack it day in and day out and
whatever team you get to you just got to
go in there and earn the respect of your
peers
just work hard treat everybody with
respect and really earn the respect of
your teammates and coaches and
ultimately you're playing the field
we'll talk for itself
you just gotta stay true to yourself
believe in your game and block out
everything on the outside that's
negative well I mean it's interesting
you know that Dwayne hat you know
Haskins is going to where he grew up so
fans there are really fired up kind of
Murray I mean in Arizona folks are
losing their minds to see what he could
look like so they're excited Jones is a
totally different ball of wax in New
York City I don't know if you're paying
attention they are freaking out Giants
fans are losing their minds again kid
from the ACC
not that much experience big huge
football market does this sound like
what happened with you being drafted by
Chicago yeah very very similar situation
so when I got drafted a lot of people
were surprised about it a lot of people
said I didn't deserve it and would it be
overwhelmed by it and at times it was
but I just continue to stick to the
process and at the end day it was a
dream come true for me to come to the
city of Chicago and for all these guys
and Daniel it's it's a dream come true
so they're just going to take advantage
of their opportunity that's given them
and you just kind of block out
everything on the outside there's the
only way to win people over is by
winning games and you can't do that day
one you just gotta come in earn the
respect to your peers or earn the
starting spot and then get it turned
around but it's definitely gonna be
tough and I had to go through it as well
but it's a learning process but if you
just work hard continue believe in
yourself stay true to who you are it'll
all work out but you just got to
remember at the end of the day that
we're it's a blessing to even have this
type of opportunity so I just got to
make the most of it yeah I know
especially since what you have been able
to do in the first couple years in
Chicago leading a draft quarterback
class that now also has last years MVP
in it obviously everyone knows who
deshaun Watson is as well was that part
of also your adjusting process knowing
who else you were being compared to as
well for sure all the time you're always
going to be compared to the guys you got
drafted with and lucky enough for me I
have a good relationship with the Shawn
and Pat and I'm rude
for those guys but as a competitor it
always motivates me that I'm being
compared to those guys and I want to go
out there and and always put my best
foot forward and make sure I'm improving
my game and mastering my craft and just
continued up prove myself right and
others wrong on the outside it's all
about st. Jude my teammates and doing
what my team needs me to do a few more
minutes left here with Mitchell true
Biscay Bears quarterback so yeah I want
an actual specific answer here very odd
that I would front load the question
this way but you'll understand because I
ask a lot of people certainly in your
position having won a division in year
two in Chicago fans are starving for
more so what do what can you improve
give me a part of the game from last
year where you may be driving around
behind the wheel of a car or you have a
couple moments to just think to yourself
you're like okay that moment I'm gonna
learn from that I'm gonna do it a little
better this time around
do you have something specific like that
for me please yeah so for us the focus
on this year would just be being a lot
better than situational football just
being a lot better in the red zone on
third down to minute before half and
finishing game so we want to come out
strong clean execution across the board
just getting guys lined up playing fast
and making the defense adjust to us not
us to them so so was going a lot more
points and then being super aggressive
was there was there a game specific
where you feel like yeah that was one
one where I could have done better in is
there a specific game from last year
that leads to my thing for us is we
thought glimpses of what we were capable
of so we gotta just put it all together
just offensively and get it all put
together okay
yeah play four quarters of clean
football just each situation each game
and sometimes we did in the second
quarter sometimes we did the fourth
quarter sometimes we don't start down
but really completing the full package
is dominating the red zone dominating
third down and doing it for four
quarters consistently alright so how
often you think of a your player
experience Mitchell all the time every
day every day seriously you think about
it every day yeah you got to let it
motivate you and it was such an awesome
opportunity we had so much fun doing it
but it didn't end the way we wanted to
so this year we got to make sure it does
okay before I let you go sir when you
said earlier in our conversation that
you play with a chip on your shoulder
were you referring to gone rogue
Mitchell we referring to this at the
chip I I do now so I'm excited to launch
with gone rogue in what is that a new
it's a new snack that is high in protein
17 grams per bag mm-hmm and it's got the
crunchiness of a potato chip
but it's protein rich just like jerky so
it's lean chicken that's been smoked and
baked hmm and they got all these awesome
flavors and my favorites BBQ and you can
get them on Amazon so it's an amazing
new snack and I'm very excited to be
with Don rock and the launch of their
high protein chips it's it's a pretty
unbelievable snack so it's pretty cool
to be a part of it okay gone Road snacks
calm or on Amazon
are you a Game of Thrones fan Mitch I am
I'm actually just get just getting into
that started it a month ago and I just
caught up so I'll be ready for the new
episode this Sunday but I couldn't watch
the last one the new ones last week I'm
just now on fees and so hold on a minute
all right hold on
so you started watching a game of
Thrones last month last month and I had
to start from Season one I was like what
is all this hype about okay I have to
get on I have to get on this so I
started watching it and now I'm all cut
up I'm ready for this Sunday okay so you
watched last Sunday you're up to speed
is what you're saying you're completely
not yet I have to watch I have to watch
three more episodes and then then do one
coming out oh gosh man yeah last month
and a half when I'm not training and
doing football stuff it's either
football Game of Thrones I mean that's a
deep quick starting noon
nobody spoiled last Sunday for you yet
no I've been off social media and I've
just been ripping the seasons on my own
oh my gosh
alright man well then I will let you go
because last Sunday and you need to just
don't have those rabbit ears going do
not yes hey thanks for joining Mitchell
on appreciate it you got it
@m true Vicki ten on Twitter but don't
expect him to tweet you back right now
he's gonna be off until he sees Game of
Thrones for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app